we are excited to announce the launch of
our official anime out for web site at
animal port calm we're kicking things
off with the Opie AF collection created
by pro manga artist Puzo midi featuring
such overpowered designs as signs all
gone and the world is yours harem King
Deku gotta smash them all the sin of
pride s Kannur praised the Sun and the
beasts Titan in full beast mode visit
enemy or calm or click the link in the
description thank you
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
looking at one of the biggest mysteries
an attack on Titan the contents of the
basement and explaining one of the most
mysterious characters an attack on Titan
Grisha Jaeger in the official attack on
Titan guidebook Grisha scored off the
charts 11 out of 10 in mystery and today
we'll be revealing all his secrets if
you like the attack on Titan content
make sure to give the like button a
colossal smash to let me know and if
you're new to the channel subscribe and
use the Titan power of your choice to
ring that magic YouTube Bell and join
the notification nah c'mon now this is
gonna be a crazy video if you haven't
read the manga mind-blowing so you have
a choice you can take the red pill and
keep watching but trust me there's no
going back after that or you can take
the blue pill click away and nothing
changes there are mind-blowing manga
spoilers about the biggest secret in
attack on Titan you've been warned now
let's make like the survey Corps and
begin to explore beyond the known world
of the walls so what's in the Jaeger
basement I have to admit this was one of
my favorite parts of the whole manga so
far because it was such a big twist kind
of like the twist in the sixth sense or
in the murder of Roger Ackroyd the
basement seems normal at first but Mika
sir manages to find a keyhole Erin's
keyed the one that Grisha gave him
unlocks this drawer that appears to be
empty
however Levi quickly realizes there's a
fake bottom and pulls it out revealing
three books these three books contain
information about titans about grisha's
past and about the world behind the
walls that's right there's a thriving
world beyond the walls where technology
has progressed much further than it has
within the walls the team finds a
photograph of Grisha and his old family
a technology that is not available
within the walls we also discovered that
there's blimps outside the walls and
that technology is progressing so fast
that even the power of the Titans will
soon be eclipsed by it thus rather than
being the last of humanity the people
within the walls are actually separated
from the rest of humanity and are behind
them in terms of technological
developments now let's turn to grey
history he was born in the lab aerial
internment zone as an LD LD ins are
second-class citizens who are often
discriminated against by the ruling bar
lands the people of Marlay keep the
audience caged in internment zones and
make them wear armbands that mark them
as ldiots it is so bad for the LD ins
that Marlon's can kill al diem children
and get away with it the LD ins really
have no rights it is said that the LD
ins have to suffer this cruel and unfair
treatment because their ancestors use
the ability to turn into Titans in order
to oppress all other peoples the Marlon
government the controlling power gets to
tell a history that serves their own
interests and this history argues that
yamir the first ancestor of the LD ends
also called the subject of yamir got the
power of the Titans by making a deal
with the devil thus yamir is looked at
as the pawn of the devil in the official
history and LD ins are as a result seen
as Devils
when empowered the LD ins apparently
designated all other races as inferior
stole other people's possessions wiped
out many bloodlines and force others to
have their children it is said that the
LD ins committed ethnic cleansing for
1,700 years before the once great nation
of Marley began to plot against them I'm
sure that when Marley was in power
before the audience took over they
abused the power to but the official
history only focuses on the LD and
cruelty anyways the merlion side managed
to get their hands on seven out of nine
titan powers and managed to use the
titans to come to power again under the
new rule the marlins became the
privileged class once again while LD ins
were seen as subhuman because of their
ability to turn into monsters called
titans and because of what their
ancestors supposedly did when they were
in power anyone who's read 1984 knows
that history is shaped by those in power
in such a way that legitimizes that
power so this version of history is no
doubt skewed but that is the history
that was being taught when Griha was a
kid as an 11 year old Grisha and his
eight-year-old sister Fay saw a blimp in
the air
blimp symbolizes something that the to
poor children could never have wealth
privilege and freedom and they are
mesmerized by it although it soon passes
from view Grisha wants to show his
sister where it lands even though it's
behind the walls of the internment zone
where Aldean's are not supposed to go
without special passes much like Aaron
Grisha finds himself cooped up inside a
wall and wants to go beyond it Grisha
and his sister find the landing spot for
the blimp but - Marlena officers spot
them one beats up Grisha while the other
acts like he is going to take his sister
home but actually has her torn apart by
dogs
- officer that beat up Grisha actually
lets him look at the blimp after he
beats him up a bit
this very officer turns out to be an LD
and spike auld the owl who has
infiltrated the Merlion army by beating
him up he actually saved Grisha from a
much worse fate when the two officers go
to speak with grisha's family about his
sister's death
the officer who killed her claims he
left her at the entrance of the
internment Zone
the owl real name Ehren Kruger seized
the hatred in grisha's eyes for the
Marlin people that killed his sister and
at that point decides to make Grisha his
successor but doesn't make a move yet
the years pass and Grisha starts
practicing medicine planning to
eventually take over his father's clinic
at 18 he comes across a patient called
Grice with a cross-shaped scar on his
shoulder he asks about it and Grice
tells him about the truth behind his
sister's death and about the LDN
restorationist a group of aliens that
are working to overthrow the existing
merlin government restore the LD an
empire and end the oppression of the LDN
people Christians the movement creating
a similar cross shaped wound on his
chest to show his devotion just a side
note but it's kind of silly for them to
mark all their bodies with a similar
scar I mean that will make it pretty
easy for the Marlins to identify them
but let's ignore that for now and keep
moving restorationist have their own
version of history for them you mere
awaken the power of the Titans and used
it to build roads erect bridges and rich
people
and developed a continent the owl
meanwhile is in contact with this group
and sends them Deena Fritz a royal
blooded LD who explains that the 145th
King who had the founding Titan power
that allowed one to control all Titans
abandoned the Audion people of the
continent he took some of the LDN people
with him to the island of paradise where
he built the three walls leaving all of
the ldiots on the continent to suffer
under Marley and rule Deena was part of
the royal bloodline that stayed because
they decided they couldn't abandon the
remaining LD ants the way King for it's
dead
Grishka vows that they will retake the
founding Titan and give it to the true
royal family referring to Deena and the
royal bloodline that refused to abandon
their people after seeing grisha's
passion Deena Falls for Grisha and
Grisha falls for her and they get
married and have a baby boy called Z
thus Zeke who eventually inherits the
beasts Titan power is actually Aaron
stepbrother the marlins eventually
create their own plan to retake the
founding Titan and create a special
warrior program in order to do it for
this program they will take five to
seven-year-old LD ins and enroll them in
the hopes that they will create royal
who will be able to inherit the six
Titan powers that Marley has in their
control and use them to take back the
founding Titan from the island I say six
because the founding Titan is within the
walls of parodies another time the
Warhammer Titan is with a royal Aldean
family called the tie burrs that help
them our lands come to power and thus
have a positive relationship with them
and the last Titan the attack Titan has
already been taken by the owl at this
time Krishna decides that the best
chance for the restorationist is to
enter his baby son Z into the program
but at seven years old z grats out his
parents and the other members of the LD
and restorationist Krishna thinks that
this is because the marlins brainwash Z
but it is later revealed that Zeke knew
that the Marlins were so close to
arresting the LD restorationist that it
was only a matter of time so he ratted
them out in order to appear like a loyal
Marlins subject and continue operating
as a double agent because if they didn't
hear it from him he would have lost
trust of the Marlins as well as probably
would have been killed himself
so he sent his father and mother and the
other LD and restorationist to the
island of paradise where LD and
criminals are taken and injected with a
serum that turns them into mindless
Titans all the LDN restorationist SAR
taken to an outer wall of Paradise
Island near the ocean of course this is
the same island where our main story
takes place one by one they are injected
with Titan serum and thrown down the
wall and Grisha watches his comrades
become Titans before his eyes
both the owl is there and the officer
that killed Griffith sister who is aptly
called gross Grisha is surprised to see
that Deena is there because while the
merlion forces tortured him he revealed
that Deena was royal blood knowing that
that would make her valuable for the
Marlins and probably spare her life he
tries to tell them again about her royal
blood but the owl shots him up and
Grisha watches Deena the wife he loves
become the smiling Titan before his eyes
after every Aldean restorationist
besides Grisha has either been turned
into a Titan or eaten by a Titan the owl
pushes grouse down the wall where he is
devoured alive
the owl aka Ehren Kruger turns into the
attack tightening kills every other
Marlin and destroys their ship he then
proceeds to explain everything to Grisha
that he was the undercover mole and
tortured and killed thousands of LD ins
over the years in order to maintain his
position and thus hope for the LDN
people he says that only one person can
make it to the inner walls of this
island and that's the person with the
attack Titan power so there was no point
in saving anyone else even Deena Kruger
kept Dina's royal blood a secret because
he still believed that death was a
better fate for her since the Marlins
would have used her to breed countless
royal blooded children against her will
Ehren Kruger explains that his family
was also part of the LD restorationist
and they were taught by the Marlins he
watched him being burned alive through a
closet door when he was only a kid he
set out to ruin Marley and restore el
dia that day he managed to find in el
dia
doctor to create fake DNA tests for him
that stated that he wasn't LDN so he
could infiltrate the merlion army Kruger
tells Grisha that the Marlins say Amir
was the devil's pond and the LD and
restoration is say she was a god-given
miracle but both stories are hard to
believe in his opinion he also says that
some people believe a more neutral story
that says she touched the source of all
living matter but he says in the end
there's no such thing as truth in this
world just different people's versions
of the truth he explains that he needs a
successor because no one can have the
Titan power for more than 13 years
because you Mir the first item shifter
died within 13 years and no one can be
more powerful than her this thirteen
year time limit is called Ymir's curse
then when Grisha seems to have lost the
hatred he once felt after he watched
gross get killed
Kruger admits that it wasn't just his
hatred that made him choose Grisha as
his successor it was mainly the fact
that he went past the wall that day as a
kid
much like the attack Titan as Kruger
explains has always moved ahead seeking
freedom Ehren Kruger gives the attack
Titan power to Grisha and entrusts him
with the mission of reclaiming the
founding Titan and restoring the LD and
Empire Grishka with the attack time
power makes his way towards the inner
three walls on the island of parodies
and is discovered by survey Corps
officer Keith sadhus Grisha claims he
has amnesia and that is how he gets
others to explain the world within the
walls to him through Keith Grisham meets
Carla who works as a waitress at the pub
although Keith likes her she falls for
Grisha after a plague appears and Grisha
comes up with the cure that saves her
and her family along with many others
with Carla Grisha has his second son our
protagonist Eren Jaeger in all
likelihood named after Aaron Krueger one
day Erin shares similar sentiments to
those that Grisha had as a kid he says
he hates the idea of spending his whole
life inside of the wall and being
ignorant of what's out there he wants to
go outside Carla is upset and wants
Grisha to tell air
to forget it but Grisha does no such
thing on the contrary
knowing he felt the same way he says
there's no holding back and inquisitive
mind and promises to show air in the
secret in the basement referring to the
secret of the outside world when he
comes home of course the walls are
infiltrated before that happens and
Grisha has to go to the Reese Chapel
where he knows he'll find the founding
Titan Freda Reese real name Frieda Fritz
refuses to use the power to stop Titans
from swarming into Shingen in a district
and killing the people inside the walls
so grizzle transforms into the attack
Titan and takes the power by force
killing the rest of the Reese family as
well except for Audrey's who manages to
escape Grisha then heads back to the
family but finds out that his wife has
been killed by now his own time is
running out because of Ymir's curse and
he decides to entrust everything to his
son Aaron just as before he chose to
entrust everything to Zeek I believe
this is why Zeek would later say to
Aaron that they were both victims of
their father because Grisha placed such
giant burdens on both of them even
though they were young children although
he felt bad about what he did to Zeek
Grisha still decided to pass on his
mission to Aaron who like him needed to
go beyond the walls and seek truth and
freedom he gave Aaron the key to the
basement before he turned him into a
mindless Titan and allowed himself to be
devoured by him and thus Grisha passed
on the tactile power the key to the
basement and his mission to his son our
main character Eren Jaeger tell me in
the comments do you think that Grisha
shouldn't have placed such heavy burdens
on his young children or do you admire
his willingness to sacrifice everything
for the freedom of the LDN people he is
a very complex character and I'd love to
know what you guys think about him and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching
the biggest secret and my favorite twist
and attack on Titan so far explained
I've been meaning to make this video for
over a year and I'm so glad I finally
did if you want more information on a
specific topic make sure to check out
our attack on Titan playlist that I'll
link into this
and at the end of this video subscribe
and attack that magic YouTube Bell for
more videos like this one also feel free
to let me know if you have any
suggestions for future attack on Titan
videos that you really want to see in
the comments and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you